foreign
[Music]
in today's original nearly a month after
the release of Avatar 2 the way of water
we talk about the future of the movie
series or more specifically about the
direct sequel Avatar 3. we give you all
the details about the story the cast and
the production as well as an overview of
the currently popular theories for all
those who have not yet seen Avatar the
way of water be aware of potential
spoilers have fun watching
in 2009 James Cameron succeeded in
making Avatar a huge hit which made the
project the most successful movie of all
time Cameron just conceived the
franchise for a total of five films and
they are thus closely related to each
other for this reason it is important to
recall the current storyline before
considering the third part's possible
plot in avatar the story revolves around
the soldier Jake Sully who lands in a
spaceship together with many other
humans on the moon Pandora this is more
than four light years away from Earth
and is said to be a potentially suitable
location for the valuable resource
unobtanium thanks to a new experiment
the paraplegic Sully is given a
so-called Avatar which can be controlled
mentally and which is based on the
appearance of the natives of Pandora the
so-called Navi thus despite his
disability he can explore the moon and
meets the beautiful nitiri as the story
unfolds Jake falls in love with her and
even switches sides to join the natives
and fight against the martial
exploitation led by Colonel Miles
courage in short Jake decides to give up
his human body and live fully as an
avatar and thus as a member of the navi
meanwhile the humans end up defeated and
Colonel korovich is killed for the time
being the danger seems to have been
averted however peace does not last
forever as we were made aware by the
second part released a few weeks ago
several years after the attack on
Pandora Jake and natiri have fathered
three children and adopted two but the
family's happiness is quickly disrupted
when becomes apparent the humans are
once again plotting an attack on Pandora
it turns out that the dead Colonel has
been resurrected in the form of an
avatar to be more precise he had his
memories implanted into one still he is
a soldier at least as determined as he
is ruthless which is why it doesn't take
long before there are the first clashes
between the navi and the Avatar soldiers
as a result spider the human child of
the Sully family is abducted and forced
to work alongside Courage the fact that
he is the deceased Colonel's biological
son doesn't make things any easier
having their home overrun by Soldiers
the Sully's escape to the metcalina clan
located on Pandora's Reeves there they
receive a not very warm welcome yet
little by little they get to understand
the new culture in life underwater in
the process loac one of the Suns meets
an outcast whale-like Tolkien with whom
he instantly forms a close Bond
meanwhile his sister Kiri discovers her
spiritual connection to Pandora's
Consciousness Iowa and spider begins to
see korridge as more than a mere enemy
in the final Clash it eventually comes
to another showdown between the navi and
the soldiers under Courage the battle
causes many casualties including nataya
the eldest son of the sullies in the end
the navi come out Victorious even though
spider chooses to save his so to speak
father from drowning at the last second
leaving plenty of options for part 3 the
sullies due to their Valiant fight are
now a respected part of the met kaina
and are preparing for the next conflict
Avatar 3 is pretty much completed
already regarding the plot there are
some hints that are currently being
discussed a lot and that we want to
further explore at this point shortly
before the release of Avatar the way of
water producer John Landau talked about
the sequel in an interview with collider
in terms of Storytelling they want to
raise the bar significantly this
includes adding more Clans to the story
and introducing new biomes each of these
involves High technological requirements
similar to the jump from the first to
the second part with representation of
the highly detailed Underwater World
thus for the third part there should be
a significant Improvement both
story-wise and with respect to the
Cinematic experience while this makes us
very excited it hardly gives us any
concrete information about the plot
somewhat more specific is director James
Cameron in an interview with 20 minutes
France which took place last December
according to the interview Avatar 3 will
introduce a new clan that differs from
the existing Navi this is a clan of Ash
people which will be strongly linked to
the element of fire with it Cameron
wants to bring in an evil part of the
navi having so far portrayed more the
good sides of the race with humans being
the Solange antagonist this black and
white thinking will thus change somewhat
in the upcoming film and there will
certainly be a few Navi among the
upcoming villains however Colonel korich
will remain as the main enemy the Sully
family will also be the folks of
attention as before thanks to the
back-to-back shooting the aging process
of the child actors is kept to a minimum
although this would only be noticeable
in the case of the human spider at most
so a particularly big time Jump is not
to be expected Cameron also revealed
that new universes will be explored at
the same time could this mean a world
beyond that of Pandora along with
Cameron's interview the cinematographer
Russell carpenter has also revealed
something about the third part according
to him the third part will feature even
more underwater scenes which makes sense
given the fact that the sullies will
stay with the met kaina an important
source of previous speculation was also
a 2018 BBC League that revealed the
alleged titles of all four sequels among
them was the way of water which proved
the leaks to be true however Cameron
recently denied that the other titles
correspond to the truth and that there
was no agreement on the upcoming titles
yet the title the seed Bearer is set to
be intended for the third installment
many reports are currently using this
title for the third movie but it is not
likely that Cameron would allow himself
to be dictated to by a leak
since the release of Avatar the way of
water there has been a lot of
speculation about how the movie series
will continue There are some exciting
fan theories that we don't want to keep
from you one Theory concerns the fire
Navi who were teased by Cameron some
suggest that they are not a real clan at
all but various Outcast individuals from
all the navi Nations a clue to this
could be a scene in the first part when
Jake wakes up covered in ashes after the
attack on the Tree of Souls according to
him he has been to a place that the eye
does not see this could be a reference
to the traditional Navi greeting which
is I see you with this in mind it seems
quite conceivable that the outcasts are
deemed dead to their Clan even though
they are in fact only outcasts thus they
are no longer seen by their former
Friends building on this many speculate
that korich will seek the favor of the
ash people in order to forge a powerful
alliance against the other Navi other
theories revolve around Kiri in the
second part not only did she feel a
connection to her biological mother
Grace but also to Iowa so it's clear
that she will take an especially
important role in the upcoming Parts it
is not far-fetched to assume that show
act as a kind of Messiah because of her
special gift at the end of Avatar the
way of water we already got a four taste
to this by seeing how she can control
and direct other living beings and thus
protect her family from Death there are
other speculations that Kiri even gets
to Earth in some way although in this
case many are referring to the leaked
title The Sea Bearer which supposedly
might not be correct it is nevertheless
an interesting idea to have Kiri perform
Miracles as a seed Bearer and Messiah on
the perishing distant Earth
regarding the cast information is still
very scarce it is certain that almost
all the protagonists of the second film
will return including Sam Worthington as
Jake Sully Zoe Saldana as natiri Stephen
Lang as Colonel korich and Sigourney
Weaver is Kiri the other children low
act tuck and spider will also come back
spider will surely play a major role
alongside Kiri as well as he's bound to
run into some moral conflicts with his
father there are also three new actors
namely Game of Thrones actress Oona
Chaplin Harry Potter actor David thulis
and everything everywhere all at once
star Michelle yo we cannot wait to see
who else joins the cast
the future of the film series depends
heavily on the success of the currently
running Avatar the way of water although
the film has long since surpassed the 1
billion US dollar Mark in box office
takings it is debatable whether the film
will be profitable for Disney the reason
for this is the high production costs of
the film series which are considerably
higher than those of comparable films
due to the complex filming for example
James Cameron's team relies on gigantic
underwater tanks in order to shoot the
relevant scenes there instead of just
simulating it all digitally moreover it
recently became known that the current
cut of Avatar the seed Bearer is a
whopping nine hours this is because
Cameron basically had all the scenes he
came up with filmed even though he
already knew that he would surely edit
out more than half of them all in all
the filming of James Cameron's declared
life's work and passion project Avatar
is anything but easy even for a giant
corporation like Disney filming is
finished and the movie is almost done
after post-production which will
probably be completed in the course of
the year the people involved will move
on to the promotional phase the final
movie will then be released in theaters
on December 20th 2024
here you go we hope you enjoyed our new
original what do you think of the newest
Avatar installment the way of water and
what would the perfect sequel look like
in your opinion feel free to tell us
your thoughts in the comments
[Music]